time now for morning rounds our look at
some of the latest medical news this
week a form of cancer caused by a virus
according to the Centers for Disease
Control 31,000 men and women are
diagnosed every year with cancer
attributed to the human papilloma virus
commonly referred to as HPV we're joined
by CBS News chief medical correspondent
dr. Jon LaPook who took a closer look at
HPV and how it can be avoided morning
John good morning Anthony public health
experts are sounding the alarm about a
rise in head and neck cancers in men
caused by the HPV virus for one man in
particular getting the word out has
become a personal crusade Michael Becker
has spent a lifetime in the business of
diagnosis and treatment of cancer that's
why a glance in the mirror two years ago
frightened him I saw this huge lump on
the right side of my neck
here's somebody who has worked with
cancer and now you're feeling this hard
lump and so I think it's cancer it was
advanced throat cancer from human
papilloma virus or HPV the same virus
causes cervical cancer but unlike
cervical cancer there's no routine
screening test for cancer of the throat
a recent study found about 7 million
adult males have high-risk strains of
oral HPV most infections clear but about
13,000 a year are linked to cancer of
the back of the throat there is a
vaccine to prevent HPV usually given at
age 11 or 12 yet only 43 percent of
teens complete the recommended doses
when you see how low the uptake is
what's your reaction anger anger we have
a moral obligation to wipe HPV off the
face of the planet Becker has detailed
his experience in a blog and a memoir
his wife Laurie I've had different
people reach out to me saying you know I
was on the fence about my son and then
after looking into it they're like you
know thank you last year Becker was in
an immunotherapy clinical trial at the
National Institutes of Health
failed he's finishing up a chemotherapy
cycle all right everybody look here
his ninth and final visit is next week
tumors have shrunk but maybe showing
signs of resistance to this treatment I
know that what time I have left really
needs to be devoted to raising awareness
of the fact that my condition could have
been avoided
John you talk about the vaccinations in
the piece and and obviously there's room
for improvement here when you've only
got 43 percent of teens who complete the
vaccinations what kind of outreach is
being done is it enough well it's not
enough but there's a lot of it you know
the Centers for Disease Control has an
outreach and the American Academy of
Pediatrics has a huge one and they're
targeting the pediatricians they're
trying to say to them look you've got to
think about it you got to make it
routine you have to educate the parents
and you have to specifically address the
questions that they have you know one of
the big questions that they point out is
a lot of parents come in and say my kids
11 or 12 why are you giving it at such a
young age they're not sexually active
and that's generally true here's the
answer the vaccine works better when
given earlier it elicits a better
immunologic response and also you want
to get them before they're sexually
active there's the doctor aspect of this
but when you look at the numbers this
needs to be a bigger part of the public
health conversation it really does Alex
the numbers are kind of amazing you know
14 million new infections a year now
before people panic 90% of those go away
on their own
but the 10% can be persistent and if
there's a certain strain then
potentially that could be the kind that
causes cancer now there's there's some
research that definitely has to be done
for one thing you have to there are
studies going on I spoke to dr. Anna
Giuliani who's doing some of the work on
this she said you know you have to prove
and and this these studies are going on
that giving the vaccine that protects
against certain strains that cause head
neck cancer that that actually prevents
the head and neck cancer so you're
preventing the viral infection it makes
sense that it would prevent the cancer
they have to prove that and the other
thing is they need a diagnostic test you
know we talked about the pap smear for
women you need something that can pick
this up early so because earlier
diagnosis earlier treatment better
results all right dr. Jon LaPook thanks
for coming in this morning John